this is crazy but it is true that it's
getting pretty close to Thanksgiving and
it's ugly cousin Black Friday the major
shopping day were stores open earlier
and earlier it used to be 7:00 a.m. on
the Friday after Thanksgiving then when
I worked at Circuit City it started
being I think 6 a.m. then it became 5
a.m. then it was midnight the night
before and now it's even during
Thanksgiving at many places Mall of
America however is deciding they will
not be open on Thanksgiving at all this
year this is the biggest mall in the
United States they've notified employees
they've notified tenants etc stores
still will be able to open if they want
but it's sort of expected that if the
mall is not formally open the stores
won't be either
here is a quote from Mall of America
where Jill renzlo the senior vice
president of marketing and business
development said we've been talking
about this for months looking at the
numbers looking at the pros and cons
we're excited to give this day back to
our employees so they can celebrate with
their families the mall directly employs
1,200 people they'll basically all be
off with the exception of I think a
couple of security people will still
have to be in if the stores all decided
to close on Thanksgiving as well that
would be an additional 13,000 people who
work at stores within the mall that
would have the day off the mall is
basically saying they want to bring the
magic back to both Thanksgiving by
letting people be with their families
but also to Black Friday so this is not
completely a move just to help out
people in letting them spend time with
their families I have really mixed
feelings about this because on the one
hand stores closing because of societal
pressure is something that I tend to be
against right so like Hobby Lobby is
closed on Sundays because it's a
religious Christian place whatever I
love the fact that businesses are open
on Sundays and on Sunday I can go to
mostly any restaurant or any coffee shop
or any store or whatever I like that on
Christmas Day or Easter I like that more
and more restaurants and coffee shops at
least in Massachusetts choose to open
because a lot of people don't celebrate
those things and they want something to
do at the same time
I recognize the utmost importance of
work-life balance and that Thanksgiving
is a time where many people not all but
many people do want to be with friends
or family or traveling growing up since
I'm not from the US my family never did
anything on Thanksgiving but we still
traveled right we would go to Montreal
often which doesn't have Thanksgiving or
or go elsewhere so I really do feel
mixed about this as a general rule I
think that stores should decide what
they want to do outside of societal
pressure so if society wants places open
on Thanksgiving and the store says no we
want people to have the time off then
that's what the store should do if a lot
of stores say hey you know what we live
in an area where more and more people we
live in a world in a country where more
and more people are not considered
considering themselves religious so
we'll be open on Christmas if it falls
on a weekday or whatever but I really
have mixed feelings and I'm curious if
either of you two want to comment on
this and if not that's fine do you have
strong feelings one way or the other
because I don't want places closed for
one religions holiday but at the same
time to the extent that we have federal
holidays I do want people to have time
for their families and their lives I
would agree with that however I really
just think that this is kind of business
driven because for a lot of stores that
five-week period is critical for about
25 percent of their annual sales yeah
and they don't want to dilute it
essentially so to speak by starting
early because in 2014 I think there was
about an 11 percent dip in sales because
they started early so I really think
this is all business driven so you're
saying the idea is they've established
that by spreading out these post
Thanksgiving shopping extravaganzas
somewhat on Thanksgiving and somewhat on
Black Friday
they sort of diluted and it it seemed
less special or attractive and overall
they sold less stuff but by saying
Thanksgiving is Thanksgiving then it's
gonna get nuts on Black Friday maybe
they're gonna get more people interested
in shopping on Black Friday
right yeah that's a possibility
definitely a possibility when I worked
at Circuit City it was a nightmare we
had to show up at 7 at 6 a.m. for a set
I am opening it was total chaos people
buying surge protectors that after
mailing in ten rebates ended up being
free or you made a buck back on it I
think with the advent of the internet
and online shopping more and more
prevalent I think more and more people
realize now that the so-called Black
Friday deals are not even really that
great deals right I mean for the most
part if you're just a savvy shopper you
can find most of these items at pretty
similar prices year-round or at least at
sales throughout the year I will not be
participating in Thanksgiving shopping
nor Black Friday shopping I call Black
Friday buy nothing day and I I don't
know that makes a difference no I I also
agree with you I tend to not go shopping
on that day so to speak but I think
another issue is that when you're
starting early you kind of run the risk
of having exhausted demoralized workers
and I think it's obviously so critical
for the energy and the stamina so I feel
like that's another reason as well yet
they would bring us terrible Dunkin
Donuts coffee at Circuit City to get
everybody ready fired up and prepared
for the big sales day we were on
commission and did make a ton of money
that day that was the only thing that
was sort of appealing about Black Friday
I think I did it three times or
something like that